so uh my first question go ahead would
you consider yourself red pill never in
a million never why in a million years
why
um I think to me first and foremost I
think I don't subscribe to any man-made
ideology okay because I think a lot of
these ideologies put you in a box
um so I do subscribe to religion and
people can argue with us man-made or not
um that's gonna be great conversation
great debate you get a guy like Sam
Harris and Jordan Peterson had a great
debate about that um but in regards to
man-made ideologies I don't really
subscribe to them as much and I don't
like to identify myself with something
that somebody else has conjured up with
their own personal opinion and so I
think in regards to the red pill is a
very interesting space a lot of
interesting characters there and I think
the the biggest challenge to me is the
the phrase that they use is that we're
all we're doing is trying to share the
truth about fill in the blank right and
to me it's very very very arrogant as a
human being to say I myself am the
orator of the truth I I know the truth
my studies are the accurate studies my
ideas and accurate ideas I am the only
individual who knows these things and so
to me that ideology seems very cult-like
in my opinion
um if you believe in them they give you
uh praise words like oh yo you're red
pilled you're an alpha male right and if
you disagree with them to give you the
the curse words right you are blue pill
you are a Beta male right are you
talking about like the comment section
I'm just talking about this the idea of
the philosophy right okay so the people
who subscribe to their worldview are red
pill individuals right their minds have
been opened up to the truth right and
people disagree with their ideas are
considered blue pill right you have
rejected the truth I.E The Matrix right
the guy in the major he said I want to
go back in the machine even though I
know it I want to go back in the machine
so to me that seems very cult to like in
regards to the ideology and so there's a
lot of different reasons why I don't
subscribe to it but those are the few
things I just I just cannot hold myself
to an ideology that a certain individual
or individuals are communicating without
understanding the influence of those
ideas yeah because they would say it's a
praxeology not an ideology yeah it's
very easy to use words like that but
then then you break down what does that
mean yeah so my question to you is like
what specifically do you disagree with
great question so when people say things
like okay we're not an ideology we're
practiology right you have to ask
yourself are you teaching any ideas like
is there any principles that your belief
system is teaching because every human
being's belief system teaches teaches
and ideas right and so for me when I see
that there are certain ideas and
premises that are being taught therefore
you cannot simply say we are we are not
an ideology there is no ideals that
represent the things that we believe and
so an example of what are some of the
things I disagree with I think I
primarily disagree with a lot of times
the descriptions of marriage okay and
just how they analyze and describe
marriage in today's world I think I just
I disagree with the analysis of a male
female nature I think if you you were to
read a book like the evolution of Desire
by Dr David Buss he's a worldly and
expert on a human evolutionary
psychology in regards to mating and he's
fantastic bus School of Psychology is
amazing and you actually read a person
who's like a world-renowned expert on
this topic and you hear about all the
nuance and I love Dr Buss because Dr
Buss understands the nuance and the
cross-cultural studies and in the so
much data and you were to read some of
the more red pill
um you know Doctrine doctrinal books
you'll be like wow like it's you it's
literally like reading Dr Seuss and
reading something like Hamlet it's like
it's like night and day difference and
so to me I think I I I acknowledge that
a lot of their ideas are truthful like
any ideology right or whatever the heck
word they're using nowadays to convince
you but that's not an ideology yes those
things are there's truthfulness in it
but there's a whole lot of lies and a
whole lot of information that is not
statistically accurate and that's why
I've always recommended people to read
books like the evolution of design by Dr
David Buss and then simply then read
whatever red pill literature that you
want and juxtapose those two ideas and
be and you'd be extremely astonished to
the differences well it's just because
everything you're saying is very broad
yeah so you even said like their
teachings on marriage because like from
my my understanding of red pill is that
they're they're not anti-marriage or
pro-marriage they're anti-marriage as it
is today and the way the laws are today
and do you disagree with that so I'm
gonna give you an example okay and I'm
excited because I'm really excited about
the way you the way you're processing
this yeah so let's go into mayor so
here's a here's a fundamental challenge
okay so red pill is very broad okay very
broad right really I don't I don't think
so actually you don't think so no so do
you do you think a person like alpha
male strategies teaches the same exact
ideas as coach Greg Adams
um I know more about alpha male
strategies than coach Greg Adams I
haven't watched a lot of Coach Greg okay
uh AMS he's like the [ __ ] these hoes to
sleep yeah but he's a vault that's old
school I don't know I just if a guy
tells me he watches AMS I'm like I got
it on yeah but but even to that point
right so you're like I gotta run yeah
yeah so so there's there's a lot of
there's then there's you know there's
individuals like Steph is Cole I'm not
sure if Steph is Cole still called
himself red pill but he had to step his
cold guys right a lot a lot different
than coach red pill okay a lot different
um okay so so what I'm what I'm what I'm
articulating is that that within the red
pill umbrella yeah there's a diversity
of individuals yeah there's far right
this and there's guys a little bit more
balance so what usually happens when
we're having this conversation which
will require so much nuance and I'm glad
we're able to dive into it is that when
you're describing the red pill what
people want to do is one of two things
you either want to steal men them or you
want to straw man them the argument that
you're probably feeling like and some
people may feel like is that straw man
them right you pick the worst ideas of
the red pill the worst content creators
and then you define the red pill as that
but then on the flip side is a steel man
where you find some of their best
brightest ideas ignore all the
negativity nonsense ideas and Define
that as a red pill no I mean to me it's
like there's a base set of ideas and
people have different ideas of what to
do with who defines the base set of
ideas um I would say that I think that's
mostly whose defines the base I would
say Rolo tomasi I think he seems to be
like leading that like today but before
it seems like it was Patrice O'Neill
possibly do you think Patrice O'Neal was
was no I I think a lot of like
um it seems like a lot of ideas derived
from him but it seems like it it goes
around Rolo tomasi that's what it seems
like so the interesting part of the
conversation going back to the red pill
conversation yeah because I know you
want to talk about this is that there is
no single Source there's no doctrinal
Source there's a lot of individuals
who's written their books and shared
their ideas as red pill and depending on
where what school of thought you're in a
lot of individuals will say well that's
not red pill for me he's not red pill
for me maybe in your world he's red pill
for you and some people red pill for
them might be called brigados be a red
pill for them might be fresh to fit
people red pill for that might be AMS to
be red pill for that might be coached
red pill from people right before them
they all seem to say the same idea well
yes yes it's like so I'm just like if
we're if we're gonna say they're
different like what what is different
okay so in regards to each individual I
can't get into nuances of each
individual so there are some individuals
who are when it comes to marriage are
explicitly marriage I think the whole
institution of marriage as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible